is named as anytime  let's take care of us  it's just that do we finish our studies  [Music]  Johanna mommy's favorite  [Music]  when I have electric you've got to do is  ice and smile like up your blades it's  true  [Music]  firming  few feet step you know  did you ever have any dreams of what you  wanted to be growing up as a boy any  like paper clean wine  [Music]  your pet silver skates over skin suit  over skins so pretty skin so racist you  have I never eat any of my skin's yeah  waking up your own type thinking they  want you  [Music]  well they took everything that we had  look at his face  [Music]  I cannot know all that you have been  through but every day we get to make a  new choice  [Music]  you  you